folks the biggest crisis facing us right
now in america is a truth crisis a truth
crisis yes we're in a pandemic yes
there's a crisis in ukraine no doubt yes
inflation's terrible but i'd argue to
you the biggest crisis we face right now
in this country is getting the truth we
can't trust the government anymore you
ever ask yourself what is it we're not
being told
folks we've seen freedom take a massive
hit just recent in the recent days and
weeks you watched it and canada a little
mini dictator justin trudeau invoked the
1988 emergencies act to arrest a
peaceful trucker protest even freezing
the bank accounts of supporters
the federal government
has invoked the emergencies act this is
about keeping canadians safe protecting
people's jobs
and restoring confidence in our
institutions the government of canada
declared an emergency today targeting
demonstrators who have tied up the
capital city of ottawa and critical
border crossings the polling on this
indicates that canadians are opposed to
what the truckers are doing and actually
would have preferred a stronger law
enforcement response if there were
election tomorrow justin trudeau would
win a landslide
but is this kind of tyrannical power
grab justified by the threat
even when all canadian airspace was shut
down on september 11 2001 over a very
real by the way national security threat
the emergency act wasn't used
then there's this remember the 2015
cyber attacks in canada the group known
as anonymous claimed responsibility for
taking down government websites even
affecting the canadian security
intelligence service website yet
no emergency act was used there
then there were the shootings inside
canada's parliament 2014 which left
lawmakers barricaded barricaded inside
their office buildings so why not use
the emergency act for that
well even the left-leaning canadian
civil liberties association they can
answer that question they tweeted quote
the federal government has not met the
threshold necessary to invoke the
emergencies act this law creates a high
and clear standard for good reason the
act allows government to bypass ordinary
democratic processes this standard has
not been met finally a civil liberties
group waking up to like a civil
liberties threat welcome to the party
yet the leaders of the protests have
been arrested under the powers of the
emergency act
so what's the truth here the actions of
the trucker protest really vindicate the
actions of justin trudeau attacking
their civil liberties well let's check
the tape
[Music]
yeah looks like a grave national
security threat to me what about you
even canada's war measures act which
predates the emergency act was only used
three times including during both world
wars
listen it's obvious we have a truth
crisis what we're being told just
doesn't align with what's actually
happening you can't trust anybody
anymore and patriots everywhere deserve
to know why we're constantly being lied
to i mean remember the january 5th pipe
bomb suspect
oh yeah i got your attention there well
whatever happened to the effort to find
that person will we ever get to the
truth about who that was
you know the fbi released video of the
suspect planning bombs that thankfully
never went off outside the dnc and rnc
headquarters on capitol hill
i'm pretty familiar with crime scene
investigation so i'd just like to
explain to you a few things so you have
this professional bomber who managed to
avoid the surveillance network of the
fbi and all of the surveillance cameras
in dc we don't see them coming out of a
car a house or a hotel managed to leave
no fingerprints on the devices no dna my
gosh it's like magic the entire fbi
source network of informants has no idea
who this guy is or woman and by the way
they got the bombs they have these
unexploded bombs and the stuff was it
was apparently a non-exotic explosive
that they couldn't detect and by the way
the cell phone calls the suspect
allegedly made they couldn't triangulate
and find out where the cell phone call
came from isn't that kind of weird so
we're supposed to accept this
professional avoid surveillance
fingerprints dna bubba you just heard
that whole thing
couldn't put together explosives that
actually went off
why hasn't the fbi launched a major
public pr campaign like they did with
the others who were on their top 10 list
listen i'm just asking questions right i
mean do we not deserve the truth on this
you're playing a few bombs i want to
know who they are i don't care about
their politics
there's the fbi
then there's the john dorm court filing
in the spygate investigation listen
we've known for years the left's been
hiding the truth about what the hillary
clinton team did to spy on donald trump
and then frame him for colluding with
russia
do you still believe the president could
be a russian asset
i think it's possible i think that's why
we started our investigation we are
looking at the possibility that the
president of the united states and those
around him during an election campaign
colluded with a hostile foreign power to
undermine the basis of our democracy
there's outright treason i mean there is
no question uh that what he is doing is
giving aid and comfort to the enemy the
political hurricane is out there at sea
for him we'll call it hurricane vladimir
if you will the whole russian thing yeah
imagine being one of those buffoons now
listen democrats are terrified we're
actually going to find out the truth
about what actually happened
yet the attorneys for the indicted
former lawyer working with clinton and
the dnc michael sussman filed a motion
to dismiss the durham prosecutor
hilariously claiming it's extraordinary
prosecutorial overreach yeah if they
heard of mike flynn and those other
cases just kind of weird now hillary
clinton she's questioning whether
conservatives or hillary clinton
questioning whether conservatives are in
touch with the truth now it is one thing
to have political disagreements
those are natural and healthy
but it is an entirely different thing
all together
to lose a shared sense
of truth
facts and reality itself
it's hard to believe what
did she just say that did that really
make it
but the truth goes a lot deeper than the
left wants you to know did you see this
key line in the dorm filing it suggests
that this operation the spy on the trump
team through multiple avenues was
potentially bigger than we know here's a
quote from the dorm filing the
government's evidence at trial will also
establish that among the internet data
and their associates exploited among the
data
if you have the reading comprehension
better than a third grader you'll
understand you know that eliminates a
lot of people on the left but that would
indicate to you that there's more there
we don't know right what do we not know
and whose agency too by the way this
clinton-connected lawyer was talking to
well according to multiple reports
agency 2 is the c-r-a
getting to the truth about exactly how
trump was spy on it's just the beginning
i think the cia's supposed to be looking
at american citizens i heard that ones
remember when the left said this is
about the intel community by the way
does the nsa collect any type of data at
all on millions or hundreds of millions
of americans
no sir
it does not
not wittingly
you take on the intelligence community
they have six ways from sunday at
getting back at you
man he wasn't kidding was he folks
listen it's not just right-wing media
talking about this here's cnn from 2017.
remember this article british
intelligence passed trump associates
communications with russians onto u.s
counterparts which means u.s
counterparts in intelligence right was
that story true then is it true now has
it been redacted are they correcting
that who are their u.s counterparts we
being told the truth remember where we
started here
folks it's pretty simple we're going to
have to continue with this crisis after
crisis until this country until we
confront the biggest crisis of them all
getting to the truth
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else